c'est également en province à marseille
nice et montpellier notamment après son
adoption à l'assemblée nationale le
projet de loi sur l'extension du pass
sanitaire est examiné par le sénat de
cuisine
seuls 11 % de la population soit
vaccinée le variant d'altaï très
présents alors les autorités ont décidé
de mettre à l'isolément les zones
plus à risque la moitié des australiens
sont ainsi confié mobilisation géante il
ira sydney à melbourne pour dénoncer les
mesures de restriction des affrontements
ont éclaté entre la police et les
manifestants
et puis emmanuel macron à tahiti
aujourd'hui et demain une visite en
polynésie française au programme le
codis bien sûr mais aussi des enjeux
climatiques les l'épineux dossier des
essais nucléaires
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france
des manifestants anti pas sanitaires se
sont rendus sur les champs elysées où
des heurts ont éclaté avec les forces de
l'ordre qui ont fait usage de gaz
lacrymogènes
il faisait partie de l'un des trois
cortèges parisiens nous vivons
aujourd'hui dans le cadre d'une grande
journée d'action nationale pour dire non
à cette mesure et à son extension sur
tout le territoire est la dispersion
elle est terminée maintenant après l'
usage de canons à eau
au total neuf interpellations dans la
capitale parmi les onze mille
manifestants selon le ministère de
l'intérieur et au total ce sont 161
mille manifestants qui se sont mobilisés
sur tout le territoire et coûté ses
réactions
quant aux manifestants la vaccination à
chacun doit avoir le droit de le faire
ou pas ça c'est pas le problème mais le
problème c'est que il va la mettre une
ségrégation parmi la population
en fait c'est juste un passage c'est
pour nous diviser et ensuite le patient
ni tard ce sera pour tout le monde qu'on
se vaccine moi j'ai pas de problème avec
le vaccin
j'ai un problème avec le fait qu'on
m'interdise de continuer à garder une
vie normale parce que je le fais pas et
ça c'est pas une manoeuvre
normal c'est pas une manoeuvre
acceptable en fait ce pas finalement une
manoeuvre d'un état libre c'est demain 9
victoria progressivement on va se
retrouver dans une dictature pure et
dure comme en corée du nord à dose
homéopathique sans qu'on s'en aperçoive
là ils veulent nous obliger à nous
vacciner il commence par certains
fonctionnaires soit disant qu'ils s'en
font tard au contact et ça va finir par
toute la population
un rassemblement statique a également
cet après midi sur la place du trocadéro
à les précisions c'est avec estelle
farges
il était à plusieurs milliers de
personnes à s'être rassemblés ici cet
après midi sur la place
durga dayraut un rassemblement pour dire
non à l'extension du pass est sanitaire
mais aussi non à la vaccination
obligatoire pour certaines professions
le moa qui est revenu le plus ici sur ce
rassemblement c'est le moël liberté tout
simplement parce que pour ces
manifestants l'extension de ce pass à
sanitaire correspond à une privation de
leur liberté des manifestants qui se
sont rassemblés aux alentours de 14
heures tout au long de l'après-midi à
des prises de parole ont été organisées
sur une estrade installée sur la place
le rassemblement était organisé par
florian philippot le président a des
patriotes et ancien numéro deux du
rassemblement national qui a appelé à un
boycott non seulement du pass sanitaire
mais aussi à un boycott des lieux qu'ils
exigent
je vous propose de l'écouter et si
encore un semblant de démocratie en
france les gens écouteront ce qui se
passe le conseil constitutionnel
censurera ce texte
et s'ils écoutent pas de toute façon on
organisera le blocage général du pays on
fera un boycott vacciner comme non
vacciner les gens n'utiliseront pas leur
passé à l'état pour ceux qui en ont un
et les gens ne le feront pas pour les
autres et ils n'iront pas dans les
établissements soumis aux passes
sanitaires ils renverront leur
abonnement dans les salles de sport
cinéma etc
le boycott général pour forcer ces
établissements a demandé à exiger du
gouvernement macron la fin de cette
folie la fin du pass de la honte
voilà pour aller revendications je vous
rappelle que depuis mercredi et bien se
passe sanitaire est obligatoire pour
avoir accès à des lieux culturels et de
loisirs c'est le cas par exemple des
cinémas et des manifestations à nice et
montpellier marseille également à rennes
par ailleurs plus de 2000 manifestants
comme vous voyez ici
et jusqu'à 4000 à nantes ou encore à
strasbourg à lyon quatre personnes ont
été interpellées lors de la
manifestation et tout au long de cette
journée
eh bien nous invitons réagi au sujet du
passeur et un jeu propose de les écouter
se passe et doit être fait d'une manière
volontaire et pas contraignante et on
voit que petit à petit comme on nous
avait vendu un vaccin non obligatoire
celui ci nous pousse à nous faire
vacciner en plus il a été imposé lors
des vacances des vacances où tout le
monde a été pris de court pour se mettre
comment dire en règle et du coup on se
retrouve maintenant certains coincé
d'autres aussi et c'est très important
de le dire aujourd'hui manifestent ils
sont vaccinés
parce que ce pass sanitaire va
effectivement aller vers une ségrégation
je souhaite conserver la liberté sur le
long terme et d'une manière définitive
de consommer de sortir de partir en
vacances d'aller dans les magasins
et si un quatrième confinement sur
données madame ce serait très grave pour
l'état d'esprit de nos citoyens ce
serait très grave
sur un plan économique et l'aveu insiste
lourdement que représentent des
commerçants indépendants 450 milles
ce sont des petites entreprises elles
sont suffrages il croit même que les
autres
et si d'aventuré on était à lugos
campine et ce serait pas mal
le but est en fait de permettre à plus
long terme de garantir la liberté de
tous dans la sécurité à nouveau tous les
lieux qui seront régies par le pass and
i ter seront garants de l'absence de
risque de contamination
d'ailleurs le pass anita permettra bien
sûr le maintien de ces vies de lieux de
ces deux de ces lieux de vie sociale
d'interaction de ces lieux d'activités
économiques
un certain nombre de nos libertés les
plus fondamentales sont remises en cause
et je je je doul
mesure la modération du professeur ben
guerdane que j'entends par ailleurs
souvent qu'il a confiance dans la
médecine et dans la science ils avaient
leurs sans doute raison qui comment dire
contout qui nous dit au fond nous
arriverons à vaincre ce virus et être
démis pourquoi pas très bien mais
certainement pas de mon point de vue en
tout cas en rabotant comme c'est le cas
une fois de plus les libertés
individuelles et fondamentale des
français et je pense être consultés
cette contestation pardon est une forme
de synthèse après son adoption par à les
députés le projet de loi d'extension du
pass 5 hectares est examiné par les
sénateurs le sénat qui a voté contre le
passage à l'état pour les 12 17 ans mais
aussi contre l'obligation de le
présenter pour consommer en terrasse
ainsi qu'aux pour le report au 15
septembre de son application aux
employés des lieux concernés sia a pas
sanitaire déjà en vigueur dans certains
lieux c'est le cas des discothèques une
vaccination ou un test négatif est
exigée à l'entrée des boîtes de nuit
malgré cette mesure des foyers de
contamination ont été identifiés dans
les vieux look turne alors sont ils des
lieux à risque où les règles ne sont pas
bien respecté éléments de réponse avec
quentin mauclair sortir son smartphone
pour scanner sont pas sanitaires un
geste qui commence à devenir une
habitude pour les français les boîtes de
nuit ont été les premiers lieux où le
pass sanitaire a été instauré pour
autant deux foyers de contamination y
ont été identifiées ce vendredi dans les
vosges 44 personnes ont été testées
positives aux variants delta après un
passage en discothèque
alors que dans le doubs ce sont 85
fêtards qui ont été infectés ce vendredi
matin le président du conseil
scientifique a estimé que les boîtes de
nuit restent des lieux à risque tant que
le protocole sanitaire ne sera pas
respectée à la lettre
on doit souvent de l'alcool quand même
en discothèque donc la perte des gestes
barrière peut se faire et je dis que
c'est un endroit possiblement de
clusters comme ça a été montré dans
d'autres pays européens
je dis seulement que c'est un endroit à
risque avec le pass sanitaires on peut
aller en discothèque
tant que le pass sanitaire n'est pas
complètement mis en place je dirais
faisons attention parce que c'est un
lieu de clusters afin d'empêcher
l'apparition de nouveaux foyers
épidémiques un syndicat du secteur
proposent de renforcer des critères
d'accès concrètement que les tests pcr
ou antigénique présentées datent de
moins de 12 heures contre moins de 48
heures actuellement
l'objectif du test de moins de 12 heures
c'est de freiner le nombre de clusters
possible dans les discothèques
quand vous aurez tous les autres métiers
qui auront des tests en effet de 48
heures et pas de contrôles d'identité
nous avec un test de 12h et du contrôle
d'identité donc un rapprochement entre
le porteur du sanitaire et son identité
je pense que là on va vraiment freiné et
si on arrive à avoir un cluster toutes
les tous les quinze jours trois semaines
je pense que ça sera une réussite en
plus de ces deux foyers de contamination
un autre a été détecté à bordeaux mardi
dernier des failles dans l'application
du protocole ont été évoqués selon
thierry fontaine les établissements
n'appliquant pas les contrôles liés au
passage du ter doivent être sanctionnés
elle témoigne de nuit de contrôle pas
les entrées il faut les fermer
il faut les sanctionner en effet le
professionnel ne fais pas ça et se
permet de faire entrer des gens qui
n'ont pas un passé a été résident ou qui
n'est pas une pièce d'identité qui
correspond à spa sanitaires eh bien il
faut les sanctionner
je pense que le mauvais travail de deux
ou trois ne doit pas sanctionner une
profession qui a tellement souffert
depuis 16 mois dans son intégralité
l'apparition de foyers de contamination
dans les dix
coatex alimente des reproches adressés
au monde de la nuit alors que la
situation sanitaire continue à se
dégrader en france pour la première fois
depuis 15 semaines le nombre de
nouvelles hospitalisations et admission
en soins critiques en une semaine a
augmenté les boîtes de nuit ne sont pas
les seuls lieux où apparaissent des
foyers de contamination ces derniers
jours en vendée au moins 22 foyers
épidémiques ont été identifiés dans des
campings par l' agence régionale de
santé des pays de la loire la seine et à
pour accéder à certains lieux publics
vaccination obligatoire pour certaines
professions il n'y a pas qu'en france
que ces mesures est stricte et sont
appliquées c'est le cas également de
l'italie ou de la flowback et là bas
également en ces règles sont loin de
faire l'unanimité on voit cela avec
emilie google ils sont des centaines à
s'être réunis devant le parlement
drapeaux et pancartes à la main pour
montrer leur mécontentement car ce jour
là les parlementaires doivent approuver
de nouvelles règles censées décharger
les personnes vaccinées de certaines
restrictions
les manifestants dénoncent ce texte qui
rend la vaccination obligatoire
certains députés dénoncent ces
protestations
d'autres les soutiennent je n'ai pas
appelé à manifester
la situation est tellement critique que
les gens devraient être carrément à
l'intérieur du parlement qui sont pour
nos droits pour mes droits et se bat
tous pour ceux qui refusent la
vaccination obligatoire
nous avons ici beaucoup de personnes
dérangées qui risquent non seulement
leur vie mais aussi celle des autres les
incidents ne se produisent pas seulement
devant le parlement mais dans toute la
ville par exemple ils essaient
d'emprunter les transports en commun
sans masque il faut faire quelque chose
par rapport à ces personnes
alors que des manifestants ont tenté
d'entrer dans le parlement les forces de
police ont dû intervenir pour les
disperser
un policier a été blessé en italien en
revanche le pass sanitaire n'est pas
aussi contraignant qu'en france
notamment appelé laisser passer vers il
entre en vigueur le 6 août il sera
nécessaire pour s'asseoir à l'intérieur
d'un bar ou d'un restaurant ou encore
pour aller à la salle de sport et au
cinéma mais pour un café au comptoir ou
à l'extérieur sur les terrasses il ne
sera pas exigée pour ce qui concerne les
bars et les restaurants si je comprends
bien on pourra rester dehors sans
laisser passer vers donc ce sera
probablement un problème en hiver
certains restaurateurs se montre tout de
même perplexe
que dois-je faire avec quelqu'un qui a
une maladie chronique et qui ne peut pas
se faire vacciner
je dois refuser de le nourrir dites moi
comment faire expliquer moi je suis
restaurateur ici à côté du panthéon mois
rome et je suis vacciné je ne sais pas
quoi faire je suis très dubitatif quant
à cette nouvelle règle impasse sanitaire
lancé cette semaine par le gouvernement
pour contrer une augmentation des
infections aux kovy 19 mai en attendant
l'hiver il ne devrait pas mettre
beaucoup de clients à l'écart dans le
centre de rome
la plupart des bars et restaurants ont
installé des tables à l'extérieur
l'australie est un pays qui faisait
figure de bon élève dans sa stratégie
anti qu'ovide le variant delta change la
donne très présent dans le pays est
réputé contagieux et virulent et l'a
contraint les autorités à confiner
certaines zones des manifestations
d'ampleur ont été organisées ira à
sydney et à melbourne pour dénoncer
cette décision des heurts ont éclaté les
points avec nicholas pettit des rues
désertées à sydney la vie est au ralenti
confronté au regain de l'épidémie depuis
le mois dernier les habitants de la
région ils sont confinés et les effets
de ce confinement tarde vraiment à se
faire ressentir
après un nouveau record d'infection ce
vendredi les autorités de l'état de ci
tenait la nouvelle galles du sud ont
estimé que cette flambée relève de
l'urgence nationale
je tiens souligné le fait qu'à partir
d'aujourd'hui le gouvernement de la
nouvelle galles du sud va demander au
gouvernement fédéral de recentrer notre
stratégie nationale de vaccination
il ne fait aucun doute que si nous
venions contenir ce virus et l'empêché
de sans filtre et dans d'autres parties
de grand sidney d'affecter notre liberté
notre commune mais aussi l'empêcher de
se propager dans d'autres états on
devrait avoir une discussion sur le
recentrage de la stratégie nationale de
vaccination en raison de commandes de
vaccins tardive et de la limitation des
stocks du sérum de pfizer à l'échelle
mondiale les régions les plus peuplées
d'australie dont la nouvelle galles du
sud sont confrontés à une pénurie
le deuxième vaccins autorisés dans le
pays celui d'astrazeneca serait de plus
boudée par les australiens parce qu'il a
dans de rares cas provoquer la formation
de caillots sanguins
au total seulement 12% de la population
sont pour l'heure vacciner mais le
premier ministre australien ne compte
pas changer ses plans chamboulé le
programme de vaccination dans le reste
du pays
ce programme de vaccination est en cours
et atteint ses objectifs et nous voulons
que cela continue
le variant delta du virus se transmet
manifestement a vite et nous avons
besoin
un peu tous les autres états et
territoires on a mieux à se rapprocher
des objectifs objectifs que nous devons
nous fixer pour nous assurer que nous
pouvons accomplir ce travail dans
l'année un appel à l'unité alors que la
stratégie nationale de vaccination
semble atteindre ses limites depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire l'australie
s'est fixé pour but 0 cas de
contamination une politique basée sur la
fermeture très strict des frontières et
le traçage qui a eu son efficacité
jusqu'à l'émergence du variant delta
depuis le mois de juin malgré le
confinement
la courbe des nouvelles infections ne
faiblit pas signe supplémentaire que la
donne a bien changé
la première ministre néo zélandaise
racines d'aar dern a de son côté annoncé
la suspension pendant au moins huit
semaines de la bulle sanitaire commune
avec l'australie permettant aux
ressortissants des deux pays de circuler
sans obligation de 40 m
une aide qui fait polémique la france au
chevet de la tunisie paris a décidé
d'envoyer du matériel médical aux
hôpitaux tunisiens de l'oxygène
notamment arrivé a envoyé également des
vaccins astrazeneca bémol il s'agit du
vaccin le plus boudé par les français
alors de l'autre côté de la méditerranée
bien on s'interroge des explications
avec notre correspondant un au maghreb
bassem chili l'aide internationale
continuent à affluer pour permettre à la
tunisie de faire face à cette quatrième
vague de l'épidémie de coronavirus
particulièrement meurtrières la france a
annoncé la mise en place d'un véritable
pont maritime jusqu'à mi août pour
soutenir le petit pays du maghreb dans
sa lutte contre le co lead 19 ce
vendredi cinq cent mille doses de vaccin
sont arrivés par la mer dans le port de
radès dans la banlieue de tunis au total
paris a déjà fourni 6 124 mille doses du
vaccin astrazeneca dans 324000 à travers
l'initiative kovacs auxquels devraient
s'ajouter prochainement
cinq cent mille doses du vaccin jantzen
jean-baptiste lemoyne le secrétaire
d'état chargé du tourisme et des
français de l'étranger et de la
francophonie a même fait le déplacement
à tunis pour accompagner une livraison
d'oxygène de vaccins et de matériel
médical parmi les doses de la france des
doses du vaccin d'astrazeneca un sérum
controversée en raison de certains
effets secondaires
et que la france a eu du mal à écouler
sur internet les réactions de certains
tunisiens ne se sont pas fait attendre
vous montrez votre solidarité au peuple
tunisien en lui envoyant des doses de
vaccin inefficace et dangereux dont les
français ne veulent pas vous prenez la
tunisie pour votre poubelle
vive l'amitié 46 millions de doses en
deux mois soit pas assez pour vacciner
tout le monde avant septembre
les doses offerte à la tunisie sont des
doses astrazeneca alloués aux dons pas
cher et personne n'en veut ici de rien
astrazeneca en france pour les plus de
55 ans et il est boudé par tout le monde
la france à vider ses placards pour
recevoir pfizer et nous a donc donné
sous forme d' aide les vaccins
astrazeneca ici en tunisie on a décidé
de l'administrer aux plus de 45 ans du
n'importe quoi côté politique on
temporise pour nabil hadji député du
courant démocrate
le vaccin d'astrazeneca a fait ses
preuves des chercheurs et des médecins
tunisiens l'ayant même à prouver
face à la gravité de la situation toute
forme d' aide notamment les dons de
vaccins est la bienvenue en tunisie
écouter le vase dans le contexte
sanitaire dans lequel se trouve la
tunisie il me semble que nous ne pouvons
pas nous payer le luxe de sélectionner
les vaccins nous sommes face à une
propagation de l'épidémie l'ensemble des
vaccins disponibles a reçu l'approbation
de l'eau et metz avec certaines
recommandations par exemple pour celui
d'astrazeneca qui doit être administré
aux plus de 45 ans nombreux pays n'ont
utilisé que ce vaccin est comme vous le
savez en tunisie avec tout le respect dû
aux fabricants de vaccins on peut
utiliser un médicament ou un vaccin
qu'après son autorisation de mise sur le
marché
donc les services sanitaires tunisiens
ont fait leurs vérifications et nous
avons confiance en nos chercheurs et nos
médecins qui ont évalué l'efficacité de
ce sérum et les risques qu'ils
présentent nous pouvons faire confiance
à notre état et en particulier à nos
scientifiques et nos médecins
je pense que nous pouvons être rassurés
puisque ce vaccin a reçu leur
approbation
au total ce sont près de 3,2 millions de
doses de vaccins que la tunisie a reçu
grâce à l'aide internationale
ce chiffre devrait atteindre les 5
millions d'ici la mi août les états unis
l'algérie l'âge
ils ont entre autres eu aussi fourni des
vaccins à la tunisie ou la campagne de
vaccination a eu beaucoup de mal à
démarrer faute de sérum le 19 juillet
dernier seuls 13,6 pour cent de la
population a reçu une première injection
7% ont pu bénéficier de doses et la
visite des moniales macron à tahiti un
déplacement de deux jours durant lequel
il sera question de la crise sanitaire
du pima et d'un dossier délicat celui
des essais nucléaires que la france a
réalisé en polynésie de 1966 à 1996 est
les polynésiens attentes des
dédommagements et des excuses la table
ronde tenue à ce propos fin juin n'a pas
vraiment permis de régler la question
j'espère je souhaite sincèrement avec sa
venue ça va faire évoluer les choses que
ça soit pour le nucléaire
ou alors pour les autres problématiques
du territoire nucléaire boulot
indemnisation kovy vaccination voilà
réunis pour trois jours avec un nombre
de personnes autour de personnes qui
vont les fils je pense avec lui c'est
des milliers de rouges pause qui doit
dépasser
j'ai pas voilà ça c'est mon ami en trois
jours quatre jours j'ai compris tu vas
rester
et voilà j'y vais pour s'excuser pour le
nucléaire pourquoi pas c'est bien que le
président vienne en devises et non
simplement pour une chose il ya beaucoup
de choses la bombe atomique
et en plus ce pouvoir que les tahitiens
sont mitigés sur les vaccins là demain
le 25 juillet la flotte russe fêtera ses
325 ans l'occasion pour les plus beaux
navires de la marine de défiler dans la
baie de saint pétersbourg 4000
militaires 54 ans navire 48 avions vont
parader sous les yeux des habitants de
la venise du nord notre correspondante
en russie verhaeghe hoffman a pu se
rendre au plus près des préparatifs
regardez 4000 militaires 54 navires 48
avions les marins russes s'apprêtent à
fêter la journée de la flotte militaire
russe cette année le défilé surtout
particulier parce que la flotte russe
fait ces trois cent vingt cinq ans et
avant le 25 juillet la date des
célébrations
nous avons pu visiter quelques navires
qui participent au défilé
[Musique]
nous sommes sur le navire c'est l'année
de ce qui veut dire vallée verte ce
navire russe a participé dans
l'opération antiterroriste en syrie en
2016 et attirer notamment deux missiles
de croisière calibre sur les cibles de
dèche
depuis mon enfance je rêvé d'apprendre
le métier de marin la flotte c'est
romantique vraiment le romantisme c'est
de quitter son foyer pour aller en mer
manqué à ses proches
attendre de les revoir et ce qui est le
plus important c'est de rentrer chez soi
chez ceux qui vous aiment
dans sa famille depuis que je suis mince
c'est déjà le quatrième défilé auquel je
pars aussi prendre part à cette fête
c'est la récompense la plus élevée pour
moi
[Musique]
et moi c'est la frégate odintsovo c'est
le navire lui +9 de la flotte baltique
russe la particularité de cette frégate
c'est qu'il est équipé de ce système un
terrien pantsir c'est le seul navire
russe équipés de ce type d'armes
[Musique]
nous sommes sur la convexité qui ce qui
veut dire résistant il est conçu selon
la technologie stealth comme tous les
derniers navires de guerre russes
et donc grâce à ces technologies sur les
radars à la place d'une corvette du
déplacement de plus de 2000 tonnes
on voit un petit bateau de pêche
[Musique]
nous devons prendre tout le vaisseau
avec son armement
quant aux membres d'équipage
premièrement ce sont eux qui effectue
les travaux
deuxièmement ils devront préparer leur
uniforme une tenue correcte ainsi que la
formation pour le passage en revue
en outre on a vacciné tout l'équipage
contre le coc u19 est à présent ses
membres sont en observation
nous avons la chance d'être à bord de
cette corvette pendant la répétition du
défilé militaire
mais peut-être pas au volant
[Musique]
le sont au coeur de saint pétersbourg
sur la neva la répétition du défilé de
la flotte militaire vient de commencer
à part la partie contemporaine les
navires contemporain les frégates les
corvette il ya aussi une partie
historique du défilé avec des voiliers
et une côté de du bateau de pierre
legrand c'est l'empereur russe avec qui
en 1696 commence l'histoire de la flotte
russe
[Musique]
rendez vous le 25 juillet sur l'aspect
france effet la fin de ce journal merci
à vous deux l'avoir suivi on va se
retrouver dans une trentaine de minutes
reste avec mon sur arte france
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk sommes au bord
de la volga le plus long fleuve d'europe
nous sommes à chevaux ksari allons faire
connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à ba là on est